The joe rogan experience.
Well,
that's a good thing.
That's that suck.
The more sensitive you are though,
the more you have to consider all the possibilities and that that's what could
keep you up.
People sleeping.
Right.
We talked about that,
right?
For the podcast.
Yeah.
There's this guy that's coming on.
His name's Dr Robert Schoch can easy geologists from Boston University and he's
worked on,
there's some real scientists that believe it's entirely possible that the sphinx
and a lot of the construction in Egypt is far older than they think.
Do you know others to know about Robert Shaw can run off how much of religion
has occurred around the base or around the pit that the,
and it absolutely couldn't have been done depending on like the way the Sphinx
is built,
where it's located,
the sighting where it's level is,
is far older.
So
yes,
they think it was somewhere in the neighborhood of 9,000 plus BC because that's
the law.
When back then the Nile Valley was a rain forest and somehow or another it
became a desert.
And this guy's,
you know,
legit Boston University professor,
geologist,
and he's traveling all over the place,
but he's here for some Ufo conference and the Ufo people wanted to him to
mention the UFO conference.
And I'm like,
fucking Christ with Ufo conferences,
you guys don't have anything.
If you had something,
it could be,
what are you gonna get together and a fucking Marriott somewhere and show,
show some blurry picture of some fucking a hubcap that someone chucked up into
the air.
Like there's nothing.
Everything that,
everything that they look at falls apart under scrutiny.
There's a few videos.
Okay,
I'm going to push back.
Please do.
Let's just say,
what about,
do you know the discovery disclosure disclosure project?
Okay.
There was their first press conference when they got all the,
I'm,
I tend to be impressed by the military,
you know,
ranking members.
I'm sort of like,
ah,
if you were,
if you were guarding missile silos and you say you saw something hover above it
and deactivate,
you know,
I'm probably going to check that out a little harder.
And there were just so many people that stood up,
you know,
in that press conference and said that they absolutely had seen evidence,
met extra terrestrials seeing the crafts,
like in hangars,
et cetera.
And to me,
like I,
they didn't look like they had that much imagination.
They're the kind of people that I didn't think could really,
I mean,
did you find that convincing at all?
No,
no,
no.
Just like a whole bunch of liars,
a whole line of liar disclosure project.
It's not so much about him.
He doesn't appeal to me as much as the people that he brought on who were mostly
millet
of the thing about military.
Anybody who's in the military is a person.
If you get a hundred people together,
one of them is out of their fucking mind.
If you get a million people,
you've got a shit ton of people that are out of their fucking mind that are
running that one extra attention.
One of the best ways to say you're you are,
one of the best ways to get extra tension is to say you've had some
extraordinary experience that separates you from the pack.
It's one of the main points of delusion that people that are really out of their
fucking mind,
well it won't want to point to.
I see things in people.
I can read Auras,
I can tell I'm a psychic healer,
I'm an intuitive person.
They all have this thing that separates them from the herd without any work
whatsoever.
I feel like a lot of these people are that they want attention and so they tell
these extraordinary stories.
Now when you said they're not creative,
that's a very astute point cause they all have the same fucking story cause it's
the same story that's been going on forever.
They just repeat shit they've already heard.
Most of these people I think are full of Shit I think is entirely possible.
That UFO is a been here entirely possible that see people have seen you at foes
entirely possible.
But a lot of those people,
my fucking bullshit radar just goes off by
bang,
Bang,
Bang.
Yeah,
I,
I've talked to too many of them and when I did that television show,
Joe Rogan questions everything,
and I met with you FOP,
Blinn bigfoot people.
I was telling you before the podcast,
it cured me cause I got to be around those people for hours and just talk to
him.
No cameras on.
I'm like,
oh,
you're fucking crazy.
Or you're delusional.
Or your way of looking at things is not objective or you're talking to me
because you want to convince me or something.
You're not just communicating the ideas that are actually in your head.
You're pitching me some sort of a speech.
You're like,
you've got some sort of a performance you're doing for me.
I smell it.
And as a performer I smell it.
I'm like,
this is nonsense.
You telling me nonsense.
You know,
they were telling you you want evidence.
I'll back a truck up and show you the evidence.
I'm like,
where's your fucking evidence?
You don't have any other audit it today.
Yeah.
Well,
here's the thing.
Did they seem as off kilter in everything else they talked about relationships,
relationship,
herbs,
jobs.
They're all screwballs.
They're almost all screw balls.
The people that are most convincing are the people that see these orbs flying
around the pilots.
Yeah.
Well,
the reason why they see these things is there's a real phenomenon called ball
lightning.
It's absolutely real and it's caused by various weather conditions and they
think that he gave in because sometimes by the right weather conditions and the
shifting of tectonic plates that somehow or another the friction.
Yes,
and that these ball ball lightning,
if you've ever seen videos of it,
it's phenomenal.
It just flies around.
They've even had an inside airplanes somehow or another ball.
Lightning has shot down the aisle of an airplane while I was in Florida actually
seen it.
Have you really enlightening on a flight that was struck by lightning?
Whoa.
It was pink and it sounded like a giant BB gun.
Hid a tin can.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
you were in a plane.
That was hit by lightning.
Yes.
Holy Shit.
That's intense.
Okay.